de stationnement ont disparu. Ça
a fait des heureux aussi. Comme
le résume Mathieu Prost.
- Son père et son fils ont
travaillé dans la cordonnerie
familiale. Elle est maintenant
à vendre.
- Ça fait mal. Après 65 ans.
Regarde mes mains de cordonnier
comment que c'est rendu.
- Pour lui, ça ne fait aucun
doute : le coupable, c'est
le réseau express vélo sur
Bellechasse.
- Qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait sur
notre route, ils ont tué notre
rue complètement. On est obligé
de fermer.
- Pour soulager résidents et
commerçants, Denis Coderre
promet de ramener
du stationnement.
DENIS CODERRE, candidat, mairie
de Montréal (Ensemble Montréal)
- Ça prend une fluidité,
assurer que les vélos puissent
passer, mais pas au détriment
de la sécurité des gens,
puis on est capables de vivre
ensemble. On n'est pas anti-
vélos, on est pro-mobilité,
puis on est pro-fluidité,
puis on veut protéger les gens.
- Sur plus de la moitié du
tronçon, à l'est de la première
avenue, la piste ne serait plus
que d'un côté de la rue,
bidirectionnelle.
- Puis je remarque qu'il n'y en
a pas beaucoup en passant, qui
passent. Fait que on est capable
d'en avoir la moitié, puis ça va
être en masse.
(roulement des roues sur
l'asphalte)
- Une proposition qui fait
bondir Projet Montréal.
FRANÇOIS LIMOGES, candidat,
mairie de Rosemont (Projet Mtl)
- Il est prêt à sacrifier
la sécurité des Montréalaises
et Montréalais, des Rosemontois
et Rosemontoises pour faire
des gains électoraux.
Ce réseau-là est un réseau
qui sauve des vies.
- Je la prends à tous les jours
Bellechasse, dans le fond,
je m'en retourne chez moi, qui
est au coin de Bellechasse puis
Louis-Hémon, puis c'est ce qui
me permet de le faire avec
mes enfants parce que... je ne
prends plus les autres pistes
cyclables avec mes enfants,
ce n'est pas assez large.
- Vélo Québec salue la volonté
de faire mieux cohabiter
les usagers, mais craint les
impacts d'une telle promesse.
MAGALI BEBRONNE, directrice
des programmes, Vélo Québec
- Ça reviendrait à ne pas
appliquer les meilleures
pratiques et c'est effectivement
une question de sécurité,
c'est-à-dire que l'on sait
que les bidirectionnelles sont,
de façon inhérente, plus
dangeureuses, qu'elles génèrent
plus de conflits
aux intersections.
- Quant à la question de la
fréquentation.
- Si on se mettait à compter
également les rues qui ont moins
de 150 passages autos par jour,
on pourrait avoir des surprises
également.
- Mais pas question pour Denis
Coderre de remettre en cause
le REV sur Saint-Denis.
- J'ai déjà déboîté une dalle
de ciment, mais ça ne me tentait
pas de me faire des bras
là-dessus sur celle-là.
- Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio Canada, M